nous poursuivons cette émission
wilfriedrichy plateau bonjour Catherine
avec vous
le savez nous revenons avec nos invités
sur les différents sujets de l'actualité
bonjour à vous quatre vous le savez nous
avons assez peu de temps je vais vous
demander d'être clair concis dans vos
réponses forcément n'hésitez pas à ceci
dit à échanger entre vous vos différents
points de vue le premier sujet c'est là
réforme des retraites François Hollande
Annonay quelques précisions lors de sa
deuxième conférence sommestriel de son
quinquennat c'était le 17 mai il veut
revenir à l'équilibre il le veut
enterrer le déficit qui devrait
atteindre les 20 milliards d'euros en
2017 concertation cet été une commission
est déjà en place il y aura une hausse
aussi de la durée des cotisations et de
vous favorable à cette hausse et dans
quelle mesure on va peut-être commencer
avec vous pour le Mouvement des Jeunes
Socialistes vous défendez cette mesure
du président socialiste alors d'abord
c'est pas une mesure qui est définitive
parce que
c'est ce qui souhaite c'est ce qui a été
annoncé mais au-delà de ça il y a un
dialogue social qui a été annoncé donc
moi je tire pas de conclusion trop
rapide
sur la question des annuités de
cotisation non moi je soutiens pas
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
pour une raison très simple vous êtes en
désaccord avec ce que souhaite François
Hollande là tu vois effectivement
Jacques un désaccord pour une raison qui
est assez simple c'est que la réalité
aujourd'hui dans le monde du travail
c'est qu'on cotise 36 à nuts et demi
c'est à dire que entre l'entrée tardive
sur le monde du travail entre les
seniors le taux d'emploi des seigneurs
qui est extrêmement faible entre les
périodes de la vie où il y a du chômage
on arrête de travailler etc la moyenne
des salariés aujourd'hui de cotisation
et de 36,5 à nuités et donc augmenter ce
palier là ça re conviendrait
mécaniquement à une baisse des pensions
pour pour les retraités donc c'est
évidemment pas la solution qu'il faut
qu'il faut à mon avis
entériner et au-delà de ça moi je pense
que la position que que nous on va tenir
en tout cas dans ce débat là c'est de
dire que les salaires les retraites
pardon c'est essentiellement en lien
avec les salaires c'est-à-dire que c'est
les cotisations de ceux qui travaillent
qui financent les retraites de ceux qui
sont à la retraite et donc la clé dans
ce programme là c'est la question de
l'emploi c'est à dire que si on arrive à
réduire massivement le chômage à gagner
la bataille de l'emploi mécaniquement on
résoudra la question des retraites parce
qu'on aura permis de faire rentrer plus
de cotisations et donc c'est là dessus
véritablement
gagner la bataille de l'emploi pour
gagner les financements qui permettront
d'assurer à tous une retraite
pour pour les jeunes pub justement
Nicolas Sarkozy avait conduit une mesure
de réforme des retraites le début de
l'allongement d'ailleurs des de la
cotisations je vais juste redonner aussi
quelques chiffres selon la Caisse
nationale de l'assurance retraite la
moyenne d'âge pour le départ c'est 61,8
ans pour les hommes 62,5 pour les femmes
3 mois de plus qu'en 2011 c'est l'effet
donc de ses précédents très forts votre
point de vue il faut encore allongé je
pense que la situation l'exige et on est
obligé aujourd'hui d'allonger cette ce
temps de travail quand François Hollande
a été élu en 2012 il est revenu sur la
réforme de 62 ans par idéologisme nous
par réalisme on soit revenir sur cette
réforme et aller à 65 ans comme le
propose Valérie Pécresse notamment
65 ans je vous vois les autres qui qui
vous regardent monsieur Brunet mais j'ai
l'impression surtout parce que disait ma
nature à Lévis c'est que c'est 36,
de cotisation au final on est 35,5 à
nuité de retraite donc
36,50 de retraite a fait que
l'allongement de la durée de la vie il y
a un moment on va plus s'en sortir il
faut pouvoir payer ses retraites à
travailler en tout cas devant cotiser
jusqu'à 65 et le problème c'est que si
on repousse le problème la plus tard on
va jamais pouvoir rembourser la dette
qui est de plus en plus colossale et
contre laquelle François Hollande ne
fait pas grand chose
aujourd'hui nous avons un devoir nous
aimons un devoir envers nous c'est de
travailler plus pour nous permettre de
rembourser un jour cette dette la
réalité en réalité c'est que personne ne
travaillera 44 à unités ça n'existera
pas je vais donner la parole parce que
c'est à dire que ce sera mécaniquement
une baisse des pensions à l'arrivée
personne ne travaillera 44 cotisation
pour aller au fond du sujet parce que du
coup on a peu de temps avec la politique
c'est pas un débat d'expert le vrai le
vrai sujet de fond là dans cette
histoire c'est que on assiste du coup à
un monde de la finance et un grand
patronat qui voit filer tous les ans 150
milliards d'euros qui vont dans qui ne
sont pas gérés par des fonds financiers
qui ne sont pas des fonds spéculatifs et
qui servent au financement des besoins
des salariés des jeunes de ce pays je
pense à la sécu à l'assurance chômage et
à la retraite et c'est là-dessus du coup
que le combat se situe pour le monde de
la finance et le grand patronat ils sont
fous de devoir verser ces sous là dans
des cases qui ne sont pas gérés par des
fonds financiers et donc le combat qui
mène depuis 30 ans mais particulièrement
depuis 2003 c'est de récupérer ses
cotisations là et de trouver toutes les
formes possibles pour réduire les
pensions mettre c'est une là dans des
fonds dans des fonds de pension et le
combat il est là et malheureusement du
coup là le gouvernement fait face à un
patronat mobilisé et du coup conduit des
réformes qui sont les mêmes contenus que
ce que la droite pouvait porter et je
crois que là-dessus il y a nous de notre
part une forte mobilisation à avoir
parce que les vrais soucis c'est le
financement de nos CQ etc etc et du coup
le chômage la case de l'industrie
Mathieu un revenu dessus mais pour citer
Thierry lepont il disait
un smic à 1700 euros pour tout le monde
pose par exemple la question du
financement des retraites pour tout le
monde l'augmentation des salaires et en
fait la vraie question c'est celle de la
répartition la répartition des richesses
en dehors de tout débats le combat
aujourd'hui il est là votre analyse pour
conclure on a plutôt deux invités qui
sont contre la longement on a notre
invité qui est pour vous allez trancher
j'ai une grande inquiétude c'est qu'on
se retrouve dans la situation à l'époque
Sarkozy de ça sa réforme d'un duel sans
sans aucun sens qui ne résulte au final
que d'une mesure temporaire si on se
retrouve tous les quatre ans tous les
cinq ans à avoir à faire des réformes
des retraites on va pas s'en sortir on
peut pas avoir les gens dans la rue à
chaque fois pour ce genre de sujet c'est
pas possible et le débat qui se focalise
comme enfin on agite le chiffon en
focalisant le débat sur l'âge du départ
à la retraite mais c'est c'est un sujet
mais c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est
d'abord que les personnes au-dessus de
55 ans en France sont très peu actifs on
a 40% pas seulement d'activité au dessus
de 55 ans les jeunes sont très peu
actifs parce qu'ils ont des études qui
s'allongent qu'ils ont un chômage très
élevé les sujets qu'on doit résoudre
aujourd'hui sont bien plus larges que ce
cette dualité à je la retraite qui est
un moment il va falloir tout le même
trancher il va falloir décider oui ou
non
c'est pas juste c'est justement d'aller
bien au-delà de ça c'est un système de
répartition par par point on pense que
les gens doivent pouvoir choisir leur
départ à la retraite et avoir la
possibilité de travailler un an de plus
s'il le souhaite travailler un nombre
moins si le souhaite aujourd'hui le
système fait si vous avez en privé vous
perdez 7,5 % de votre pension si vous
partez en avant si vous avez en privé
c'est 2,5 % dans le public il y a aussi
un déséquilibrage un déséquilibre entre
les régimes de retraite pour le privé
public qu'il faut absolument corriger
pas seulement privé public d'ailleurs
dans les caisses privées c'est je suis
travailleur indépendant les six derniers
mois dans le public 25 années pour le
privé exactement et au-delà de de ces
deux là et on en a beaucoup d'autres des
régimes moi je suis indépendant je suis
travailleur entrepreneur
la cotisation à la retraite c'est une
très grande question j'ai déjà le choix
de le faire quand on sait que il y a
simplement aucune certitude sur l'état
de la retraite ici 40 50 ans si on
pouvait avoir une réforme qui est enfin
donné un petit peu le ton de ce qui se
passera dans les 20 30 prochaines années
je pense qu'on avancerait on a besoin
justement la transition était tout
trouvé l'autre thématique qu'on va
aborder dans la suite de cette édition
c'est l'emploi des seniors le chômage
qui explose 3,2 millions de demandeurs
d'emplois début mai les plus de 50 ans
sont les premiers touchés même plus
encore que les jeunes ils sont 20%
contre 16% des témoins de 25 ans
représentés l'un des outils c'est le
contrat de génération l'État vers 4000
euros pour par an pour des salariés de
57 ans qui deviennent le tuteur d'un
jeune embauché lui aussi en CDI sauf que
l'aide s'arrête au 60 ans du Seigneur et
que le Seigneur n'est pas obligé ensuite
de partir à la retraite il peut même
d'ailleurs continuer dans le privé à
travailler jusqu'à 70 ans puisqu'il y a
eu cette dérogation cette possibilité
laissée ça veut dire
répondre à la crise de l'emploi du
chômage la réponse est non ça ne suffira
pas et c'est pour ça qu'à mon avis il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin il faut
aller plus loin dans les politiques pour
lutter contre le chômage et ça passe par
différentes choses d'abord rompre avec
les politiques d'austérité il faut
relancer la machine économique
c'est-à-dire réinjecter de l'argent
massivement parce que c'est ça
aujourd'hui qui fait qu'on bascule en
récession et qu'on a une rétraction de
l'activité économique donc c'est à dire
qu'il faut changer de cap et ça c'est au
niveau européen et là-dessus je crois
que François Hollande est assez clair il
engage un bras de fer avec les libéraux
européens pour une relance économique
massive mais en tout cas vous êtes
convaincu par le contrat de génération
moi c'est quelque chose qui va sachant
qu'il faut aller plus loin il faut aller
plus loin rapidement l'interdiction des
licenciements boursiers qui me paraît
essentiel et je pense que là voilà
vous êtes convaincu ou pas autour de
cette étape par ce contrat de génération
les emplois d'avenir aussi je précise
juste que l'objectif d'ici 2013 c'est
75000 contrats de génération pour
information à ce jour en ce mois de mai
dans le département des Yvelines 15
seulement ont été signés sont les
chiffres de la Direction du Travail
j'y crois pas du tout tout simplement
parce que comme je le faisait Mathurin
s'est fait pour des
des jeunes qui sont dans des situations
précaires et au final qu'est-ce qu'on
leur donne on leur donne un emploi
précaire donc ça revient à la même chose
c'est un CDI mais au final ils sont
bouchés par qui derrière
c'est là la question aussi il faut
relancer l'économie réelle et l'économie
réelle c'est l'entreprise c'est
l'industrie voilà et donc arrêter de
faire l'odeur d'os fiscal et de
d'embaucher autant de fonctionner c'est
surtout ça le problème mais je crois que
là on est dans le même ce que je disais
tout à l'heure les 30 ans de politique
qui mettent en place la case de notre
avenir parce que du coup on est encore
sur le fond là c'est des contrats qui du
coup ouvre droit exonération de
cotisation sociale qui ne financent pas
nos besoins et c'est 30 ans de
dispositifs spécifiques pour un public
qui serait du coup les jeunes
particulièrement fragiles qui nous
enferment du coup dans cette dans cette
fragilité il y a effectivement besoin de
plans d'urgence mais des plans d'urgence
qui posent la question de la répartition
des richesses et qui pose les questions
de l'avenir des jeunes de leur formation
30 secondes on a l'impression que la
gauche a l'air de croire que le l'emploi
ça s'achète que c'est en dépensant
d'argent pour des contrats à l'avenir
pour des contrats de génération qu'on va
créer de l'emploi c'est une déconnexion
complète du monde de l'entreprise dans
le monde de l'entreprise on peut pas
dire une personne sous prétexte qu'elle
est elle a plus de 55 ans qu'elle est
une personne expérimentée qui peut
enseigner c'est on n'est pas dans
une véritable réalité de l'entreprise
merci en tout cas d'être venu sur le
plateau des merci de cette émission
consacrée au municipale et pour conclure
ce troisième numéro Wilfried quelques
informations sur les candidatures dans
les Yvelines quelques précisions et il
reste encore un peu tôt pour avoir
beaucoup de de nous à vous communiquer
mais cela concerne l'UMP cette
information elle s'est réunie mi-mai
pour délivrer dans le département les
investisseurs donc pour les municipales
l'UMP qui ne souhaite pas communiquer
officiellement les noms on sait
néanmoins ça c'est sûr qu'Aurore berger
à magny-les-haussera bien la candidate
officielle tout comme à Poissy carlive
qui est également conseillé général et
puis un candidat qui n'en est plus un
c'est David Douillet député UMP il a été
annoncé à Poissy ensuite il a été
annoncé à Rouen il ne sera finalement
sur aucune des listes je vous propose de
l'écouter
moi je vais pas me présenter nulle part
contrairement à ce que peut dire et
écrit enfin il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup
de rumeurs donc je viens porter
supporter ce qui le méritent que j'aime
chez une femme ou un homme politique
c'est d'abord qu'il soit
pas passionné de sa propre vie et de sa
carrière
ça c'est pas intéressant mais qu'il soit
passionné de la vie des gens ça c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant et voilà fin
d'émission pour ce mois de mai une
émission évidemment à revoir sur notre
site Internet et puisque nous recevions
les jeunes responsables des formations
politiques sachez que le vendredi 31 mai
sera lancé la Fédération des jeunes
udies des Yvelines et nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler sur notre
antenne voilà on se retrouve en juin
pour une nouvelle émission consacrée aux
municipales